ce sont plus d'une centaine de planches
mise à la disposition du public depuis
le 19 septembre dernier dans la salle du
jeu de paume elle témoigne dernière
étroits entre le château de versailles
et l'univers de la bande dessinée
cette exposition qui est présente une
centaine de planches et consacré donc à
versailles dans la bande dessinée elle
permet de montrer comment une
quarantaine d'artistes différents l'ont
appréhendé à leur manière le château de
versailles comment ils représentaient
avec leurs techniques propres et leur
sensibilité
les pièces sont présentées dans le cadre
de l'année de la bd décrétée par le
ministère de la culture
l'occasion d'effectuer une rétrospective
historique originale la bande dessinée
historique a connu un grand regain
d'intérêt depuis une quarantaine
d'années et beaucoup d'événements se
passe justement sous l'ancien régime
donc au château de versailles il ya des
planches qui sont consacrés aux
intrigues de la cour sous le 14 ou le 15
ou le 16 à la vie de cour
au fait qu'ils pouvaient été donnée à
versailles au promenade dans les jardins
de nombreuses planches sont consacrés à
la révolution française que représente
symboliquement la salle du jeu de paume
c'est pourquoi elle a été choisie pour
héberger l'exposition cette salle a été
choisi parce que son format était
parfait idéal pour accueillir ces
centaines de planches de la manière dont
elles sont présentées mais également
parce que il ya cette grande toile qui
est face à moi qui était composé d'après
le dessin de jacques louis david
représentant le serment du jeu de paume
qui lui même est presque un dessin pour
une bande dessinée
l'exposition est gratuite et accessible
tous les jours sauf le lundi jusqu'au 31
décembre